it's really interesting because we
always have uh those people that convert
to Islam like a week before Ramadan or
even a day before Ramadan so uh you're
Muslim and you got to fast the next day
uh you know and that's always a
challenging experience for people but a
fulfilling experience for many people um
when they Embrace Islam at that point
and again I mean it's
it's it's it's simple and I think that
the beauty of Islam to many people is in
its simplicity one God one Humanity one
body of prophets um and uh one Community
because for
you as a Palestinian
American this year the
Ramadan perhaps would be especially
difficult spiritually what
uh what are you anticipating what do you
think is the the difference this
year I hope I hope and pray that we have
a ceasefire before italon I hope that at
that point we're rebuilding Gaza talking
about rebuilding
Gaza and helping
people um that have been damaged in so
many different ways I hope that Ramadan
is turning a
corner every Ramadan um
the aggression against the Palestinian
people seems to grow so we're usually
dealing with you know last 10 nights of
Ramadan and then the incursions on M AA
really sour it um for the entire Muslim
world right because you're watching
worshippers being assaulted in one of
the holiest places in the world and at
the same time you're trying to find your
deep connection your own deep Holy
Connection right in Ramadan this time
we're going in and if this is still on
ongoing um we're dealing with a
continued genocide so I think that the
mood has been somber in the community
the mood has been uh different from
anything I've ever seen before so I
anticipate this Ramadan would be
different from anything we've ever seen
before I think the focus will continue
to be on
Gaza and on um either stopping the
aggression on Gaza or beginning the
rebuilding of
Gaza so a general heaviness perme
just your prayers and your thoughts
throughout this yeah I mean look every
sermon I've given since October 7th has
had to have some inclusion of this
because it's what what's on everyone's
hearts and Minds um we also have people
in our communities that have lost 20 30
40 people right in our
midst it's not the same um you know if
we start to have refugees or people that
escape for medical treatment Tre or that
are able to get out through Egypt and
join their
families um you know it's becoming more
real right it's becoming more personal
for people so I think that Ramadan will
surround both in in terms of messaging
as well as Community uh the uh the pain
of the moment with a prayer for Hope and
healing
that